chasms crumbs and the mercy of God this
morning's text confront us with
behaviors we handle no better than
jesus' first century audience the words
of the Prophet Amos remind us of the
very teaching the rich person failed to
take seriously or for that matter even
notice alas for those who lounge and
their couches drink great quantities of
wine eat meat sing idle songs before we
even here Jesus is parable we have a
pretty good idea about what is coming we
already feel the contrast between our
self-indulgence and are corresponding
indifference to the sufferings of others
the hebrew scriptures are clear about
our obligations to embody and express
the merciful life-giving and liberating
actions of god who consistently hears
the cry of the poor in case our command
of torah is weak our response oriole
some reminds us of the merciful
character of god even before we hear the
gospel the somme blesses and praises God
for just behavior God executes justice
for the oppressed gives food to the
hungry sets the prisoners free opens the
eyes of the blind lists up those who are
bound down loves the good watches over
strangers and upholds the orphan and the
widow this is the compassionate God we
praise and in whom we place our trust
earlier in Luke's Gospel we already saw
that Jesus embodies these same
characteristics
god we are told reading the scroll of
Isaiah in his hometown synagogue he
found the place where it is written the
Spirit of the Lord is upon me because he
has anointed me to bring good news to
the poor he has sent me to proclaim
release to the captives and recovery of
sight to the blind to let the oppressed
go free we his followers are called to
perform the same merciful actions Jesus
is parable on the other hand draws us
into a drama that presents us with
questions and behaviors we would prefer
to ignore what part of the story do you
and I resist a chasm that can't be
crossed the frustrated sense of
entitlement the rich man exhibits
demanding that Lazarus relieve his
thirst or the disturbing insistence on
the lack of a second chance for the rich
man and for his family doesn't our God
remain merciful into the next life in
our self centered self indulgence do we
assume there must always be yet another
chance to get it right when we've done
precious little to discover what that
might be all along the narrative power
of the story draws us in even as it
turns our comfortable world upside down
the rich person in this story is a stock
character the rich person actually has
no name we've been so disturbed by this
we give him a name we call him D vase
which is just the Latin word for rich
man in the Greek the gender inclusive
anthropos identifies
simply as a rich person and I need to
remind us the rich person can also be a
rich woman dressed in the finest
clothing of the day equivalent perhaps
to Armani salvatore ferragamo or your
own designer of choice he not only dines
well but feasts sumptuously every day
the contrast hits us immediately Lazarus
is a poor person but unlike the masses
of our nameless poor who remain
invisible to us both inside and outside
our gates this man is dignified by a
name he is covered with open source
rather than with fine fabrics he is
hungry and longs for crumbs that fall
from the rich person's table that even
the dogs get to eat even worse the dogs
lick his open source an image that is
pretty repulsive to us to say nothing
about the potential for infection today
we know the rich and famous by name they
enjoy comfort and pleasure while the
Lazarus is suffer extreme hunger
invisibility and neglect when death
comes for both of them however their
fortunes are reversed angels carry
Lazarus to heaven where Abraham welcomes
him with a warm embrace God keeps God's
promise to the poor and the oppressed
the rich person is not so fortunate he
has been cast down while Lazarus has
been raised up not yet able to reflect
on his own behavior or choices in life
he pleads with Abraham to send Lazarus
to relieve his thirst he really hasn't
gotten it yet in the story once the rich
person needs something he suddenly knows
exactly who the poor man is calling him
by name all that he did nothing in his
earthly life to relieve Lazarus is
suffering he appeals to
Abraham to give Lazarus yet another
assignment on behalf of a rich person in
response Abraham explains the reversal
while the rich person enjoyed comfort in
his earthly life Lazarus suffered here
in the afterlife it is only fitting that
their fates are reversed not only that
but there is a condition none of us
quite wants to admit into consciousness
a great chasm separates them what once
was a permeable boundary has become a
permanent barrier that cannot be crossed
from either side it is only when he's
confronted with this unexpected impasse
fixing him in his misery that the rich
person shows any concern for anyone
beyond himself from his still
unconverted point of view Lazarus is a
servant whom Abraham should send to the
rich man's brothers to warm them of
their perilous situation even in
paradise the fortunate poor person's
role is to serve the rich the rich man
hopes that his brothers might listen to
the ghostly Lazarus warning them from
beyond the grave but Abraham refuses and
insists that Moses and the prophets have
already been quite clear about what is
required even though the rich man is in
his chase and conditions thinks his
relatives might listen to one who
returns to them from the dead Abraham is
adamant not only will they not listen to
one return from the dead they will not
even be convinced should one have been
risen from the dead I don't know about
you but that final illusion captures our
attention because it can only apply to
us we do have the experience of one who
has not only returned from the dead
but risen from the dead and we have
great difficulty taking to heart our
responsibilities to those in our
community and Beyond who suffer now
people who are poor oppressed and
suffering continue to remain invisible
to the comfortable rich we are perhaps
tidier about the way we maintain the
chasm between rich and poor than first
century Palestine if we reflect on our
own situation of privilege I am struck
by the invisibility of persons who are
poor as we consign the impoverished to
neighborhoods we never visit the chasm
that confronts the rich person in the
afterlife he first created in this one
we translate I think today chasms into
walls the miles upon miles of concrete
and barbed wire fence fencing we are
busy building along our border with
Mexico to keep our poor neighbors out of
our neighborhoods building walls is more
attractive to us than addressing the
hunger and poverty at the root of this
migration I think of the wall built
between Palestine and Israel confining
the poor less deserving Palestinians to
perpetual need in poverty by depriving
them of their ability to work and farm
beyond their own neighborhoods I think
of African American poverty in New
Orleans still entrenched five years
after Katrina and pretty much out of
sight again and I think about some of
our neighborhoods in New Haven at st.
Thomas More Chapel one morning just as
school was starting a student's mom told
me she was advised not to drive down
dixwell avenue that it wasn't safe on a
sunday morning really most of the folks
I had just seen on dixwell on my way to
church were all themselves going to
their own churches not say
but I could also not help but notice
that some of the neighborhoods along the
way are poor we too easily seem to
develop habits of avoiding the reminders
that we do not all enjoy the same
standard of living I also think of the
Pakistanis devastated by floods their
homes gone their farmlands ruined and
our rather anemic response along with
other first world countries to help them
some of you may have participated last
night in the benefit here trying to
mobilize a stronger response within this
community sometimes our poor and
suffering brothers and sisters are only
too clearly in view through the internet
and other media and this can become so
overwhelming we suffer compassion
fatigue if we care and we have an excuse
for remaining indifferent if we don't in
addition to the chasms that separate
rich and poor I was also drawn to think
about the crumbs from the rich person's
table for which Lazarus longs our world
is more complicated than first century
Palestine we know much more about the
causes of hunger than those in the world
of the parable I recently read that the
food we waste could actually feed the
world a stunning amount of the food we
grow never gets from the farm to our
plates food is wasted at every step
along the way of our own food chain a
2004 study estimates that our food waste
might be close to fifty percent an
astounding fifty million tons of food
wasted each year we desperately need to
find efficient ways to get this food to
those who need it and can benefit from
it related to these wasted crumbs from
the tables of first world countries is
the distribution of land and food
resources that favor the rich the
insistence on exporting food from all
over the world to us has resulted in
causing these countries to export the
food they grow to us while their own
people go hungry creative agricultural
movements that advocate we begin to grow
our own food again might stop us from
impoverishing our poor neighbors so we
can have every food in season or out of
season but we will be unable to mobilize
sufficient reform until we really
understand the largely invisible and
impersonal processes around food
resources and politics that maintain
unnecessary levels of poverty both here
and abroad finally I think of the poor
in our midst whom we either ignore or do
not see maybe even closer to home among
those of us who inhabit the rarefied
world of Ivy League education we made to
easily be tempted to assume that we are
all equally privileged certainly all of
us who work or teach or study or
research at Yale are privileged we are
privileged wealthy in our intellectual
gifts and in terms of the educational
background we bring to this community
but we do not all equally share the same
sense of entitlement about how we are
treated and treat others because of the
generous levels of financial aid there
are enormous class and cultural
differences among us that often remain
quite invisible who are the Lazarus's
among us who among us here in this
Chapel this morning despite our
privilege feel more like Lazarus than
the rich person who among us is anxious
about how well we're doing academically
who among us is feeling alone and
displaced without
support of our families and previous
circle of friends and community who
among us longs for the crumbs of
acknowledgement of being seen and
responded to simply because each one of
us is God's beloved and we are called to
create a rich and supportive community
for one another who among us is
struggling to look right to fit in to be
accepted whether or not we can afford it
how many among us not only are studying
but also working long hours to manage
our expenses are we willing to cross
this invisible chasm among us now or do
we carefully ignore the subtle signs of
such suffering as we allow the gospel to
question our assumptions our sense of
entitlement and our unresponsiveness to
the Lazarus's in our midst does not the
gospel also reassure us that today we
have the possibility of responding to
those who suffer in our midst today we
still have the possibility of bridging
one of the chasms that separates us
today we can share our food with one
another even as we work toward long-term
solutions today we can visit another
neighborhood today we can recommit
ourselves to the mercy and compassion to
which Jesus calls us because we live
today God meets us here both comforting
us and inviting us to open our hearts to
one another today we can open our hearts
both to the Lazarus's in our midst and
outside our walls and to the privileged
among us who have yet to heat the law in
the prophets today we can open ourselves
to the full demands of discipleship to
which Jesus calls us today we can live
in
a radical gratitude for your boundless
generosity God and we address you in the
words of walter brueggemann you give
your word to call the world into being
you give your sovereign rule to
emancipate the slaves and they oppressed
you give your commanding fidelity to
form your own people you give your life
for the life of the world broken bread
that feeds pour it out wine that binds
and heals you give we receive and we are
thankful